New black boots
Chasing necklace
Are you taking off too
Way to get back to the dudeHe said it's a
process you just.
Fingerprints and all that nothing
Yeah we just got to slide you in the door
after we slide you in the door period
Valentine letters in a busted girl
And still bleeding like beforeBaby softball.
In pieces of all fearWhiskey stains on.
Glorious
I love you we try to keep
I said
I'm actually going to vote just slip away
So
Washing is in the small village
Ult
His face have one more hands to show I'll
take it slow
Let's go
And well I still can
Believe
I've had news on me today
I understand
All FrozenOn the shoulders.
Supercharger
If you read it sounds like a Gucci sign
Free online serviceDownload.
I'm all running from Monday
Heading back to all my shit